a good memory marker is you castle long
against the dragon
you castle short against the accelerated
dragon
[Music]
so let's play
a let's play a sicilian and let's play
an accelerated dragon
uh john might also play the smith moro
okay now he's going to play the open
sitzillion
and and we're going to play the
accelerated which i think is
you know quite fitting because this is
what we normally play so bishop g7
bishop three knight f6 this is all very
uh this is all theory we've had this a
million times and
john goes f3 so this is
uh not the best and this may fall into
that opening trap which
i've referenced uh several times now
first we castle
and after the game i'll talk about why
that is
if john goes bishop c4 here then he's
already going to be in trouble
the bottom line here is that
i've developed my pieces in very much a
harmonious manner john goes queen
queen d2 which does make sense he
prepares to castle long
but there is a reason that in many
instances the bishop has developed to c4
early does anybody know what this reason
is
what move does black now happen this
move sort of stems
naturally from the way that we've
developed our pieces yeah of course we
want to play d5
that shouldn't be a surprise to anyone
we want to open up the position because
well we want our bishop to make its
presence felt
so i'm gonna recap that opening trap
after the game so he plays knight takes
c6 okay so we play bc
now our pawns are nicely connected and
the b file has gotten open so e5 that
makes sense jon wants to lock this
bishop in by playing f4
which which is a legitimate way of
playing this but i'll show you guys how
to combine it so let's get the knife
back
and there's a couple of ways
that we could go about this um
now this bishop is for the moment it's
locked
locked out of the game in the future how
could we go about
letting that bishop back in okay is
there anything we could do later not now
and i'll
actually demonstrate afterwards why this
move is not very good
right now there's a tactical reason
behind it
yeah but the move f6 essentially chips
away
at white's pawn tree now normally you
want to attack the base of the pawn
train here you don't have that luxury
you just want to get the bishop open but
um
we don't have to do that yet and i'm
looking at these two pawns and i'm
saying wouldn't it be great
if i could play the move c5 and then i
could supplement that with the move d4
these two pawns can really wreak some
havoc on white's position because he
doesn't really have any central pawns
other than the two we just referenced
so one good move is to play e6 cement
that pawn and then prepare c5
another positive byproduct of playing c5
is that this bishop on c8 right now it's
out of the game
we want it to be on b7 that's the only
possible square for it
so if we can push these pawns out of the
way that bishop is going to be occupying
the second
long diagonal and then later we can play
the move f6 at our
convenience okay so
i think our convenience is right now
because
the move f6 in addition to opening up
the bishop it also oh we have oh but
wait we have a very five head move
we have a very five head tactic how did
i notice it
i looked at this knife for a second and
i was like wait a second this knight is
undefended
loose pieces drop off i mean undefended
pieces are among
the biggest precursors for tactics and
chess so we have
and i also noticed that when he's played
f4 as i've referenced before on the
speed run
we always need to look for tactics
related to this diagonal getting open
and if you look at the knight it is in
the path of a queen
that can land on h4 so we can play
knight takes c5
now this is better than playing bishop
takes c5 because there's no reason that
we should part ways with our strong
bishop
so you can see how these tactical
elements come together thank you
e carvajal for the prime as well how
these tactical elements they come
together and
they create the environment for this
kind of a tactic so john has to decide
now whether he's taking the knight or
he's not
this is already very problematic because
we've solved the problem of the bishop
without playing f6 and we've won a
central pawn
it is true that he's pushed his pawn out
to f4 but that doesn't really mean that
i can immediately get to a king that's
castle short now castling long
i would definitely not advise because
our bishop is now so wide open although
maybe he should do it i mean maybe he
should try to
mix things up so john does end up taking
the knight queen h4
well it's a blunder because he's given
away a pawn right we've taken a pawn
and in return we've won back the knight
now this pawn is very weak and in
addition
again thinking in the same way that we
just reasoned
uh loose pieces drop off we should look
at his king we should also notice his
rook on h1
is undefended which means that an idea
such as queen e4 could manifest itself
at any moment if he moves his bishop to
defend the pawn for example guinea4
would win the rook
which essentially means that he cannot
defend this other pawn
yeah so bishop d4 what i see
is that bishop on d4 and i say well is
that a robust robustly played place to
be it's not really
as i've just pointed out and okay we'll
talk about this after the game
john goes bishop d3 he prioritizes
development which i actually think is
is is perhaps the correct approach
but uh we are going to take the second
pawn we're going to do it
as i've described before there's a sort
of curve of diminishing returns when it
comes to winning material
the first piece that you win the first
couple of pawns that you want those are
worth a lot but once you win two pawns
or once you win a piece
there's a very big curve where every
subsequent pawn that you take is worth
quite a bit less
because you only need so much material
to have a decisive advantage so you
always have to weigh that against the
the time that you spend taking
additional material
okay so bishop h6 that's a good move
john trying to create trouble for us
now we have to decide if and whether
we're even moving this rock
we can also block with bishop g7
although this bishop is a good one i
don't really want to give it away
on the other hand um this
bishop on h6 is kind of a thorn in our
side and i also don't want to give him
any undue attacking opportunities
connected with
you know a lobster pincer of some sort
or something like that
not that that will happen because we
won't give away our bishop so we won't
allow a queen to land on f6
um but i'll tell you guys the following
i actually think
let me think let me actually think for a
second
yeah i think a case could be absolutely
made to play g7
we could also try to sack the exchange
so
okay the best thing to do here the best
thing to do is would be to take on b2
so it would be to take on me to
counter-attack the rook and if the rook
moves then we would go bishop g7
i just said that we have to be very
careful when we're grabbing additional
material we do
and i was careful because if we're
already removing our bishop back to g7
then we might as well
win another pawn while we're at it
there's no
reason not to take that pawn if he goes
rook to b1 his rook gets on an open file
but
that doesn't particularly bother me in
some some grand
grand way we can also take on a2 we can
consider it but then he can castle
and that see that's exactly what i would
caution against if we if
if we were to take on a2 we would allow
him to castle he would simultaneously
defend his rook our queen would end up
being kind of misplaced
and that's what i mean when i say the
diminishing returns this fourth one
is not worth taking the third pawn was
but now let's just drop our bishop back
let's let's chill let's consolidate my
advantage let's try to get this bishop
out by playing e5
and uh once we do that uh we'll we'll be
up three puns so
greed is okay in chess to some degree
you you need
greed you need to want to win material
to some
extent but you want to draw the line
very carefully between because that line
is a very thin one
when in doubt don't get graded when
endowed prioritize peace placement and
peace activity
over that extra pawn that you can take
okay so john
doing everything he can to cause trouble
h4
okay so
let me think well we can intercept this
i think and
okay
it's not actually that easy to to deal
with this
you see it's it's not it's far from far
from elementary well one thing that we
can do
is ask ourselves what are the drawbacks
of the move h4 this move may not seem to
have any drawbacks
because it's very easy to focus on its
strengths but if we
if we reason logically one of its
drawbacks is that it does
uh create a backward pawn on g3 this
backward pawn is also a key
to white's king if we take that pawn
it'll be with check
and we can combine that with another
observation which is that this queen on
a4 is sort of out of place
it's on the queen side it's done its job
but we would really want to have it is
on the king side we want it to be
participating
in in the affairs and queen g4
seems like a very nice move because it
it kills two birds with once it
activates the queen
from a general standpoint it attacks the
pawn and the queen is now closer to our
king so it can lend its defensive
services
if necessary to the king
okay
yeah so pawns i i see a question about
me having pawns on the white squares
i've
always said that um
having pawns on the same color as your
bishop that's an overrated
trope i i just don't think that's as
important as people make it out to be
thank you john
that was a good game that was really
interesting though so let's um
let's unpack this for a second now you
played the move f3 which
which isn't inaccuracy and the the sort
of
relatively famous trap i wonder if you
i wonder if you if you know this trap
john is the move bishop c4
and does anybody know does anybody know
what black's response here is i've shown
this before to charlie i've shown this
before too to you guys
yeah and that is queen b6 so
in the accelerated dragon you don't want
to play f3 at all if you want to play
this in pure accelerated dragon fashion
you should play bishop c4
after castling you should go bishop b3
and then castle short
a good memory marker is you castle long
against the dragon
you castle short against the accelerated
dragon thank you bob
dung gifting to ak miracle man yeah so
the issue with f3 is that it's just not
sustainable you don't have the time
uh to cast the queensland this isn't
that bad and the funny thing is after
bishop c4 queen b6
uh this famous famous trap right castles
and now knight takes e4
opening up the attack on the on the
white knight white can actually equalize
here with the move knight t5
but it's it's hard to remember and even
at the end black has kind of a practical
initiative
so you know this i i don't dislike your
decision john to go queen d2
uh yeah unfortunately against the
accelerated you cannot focus
you cannot force the yugoslav you cannot
force the yugoslav
okay so d5 uh and and this i think is a
very sensible approach e5 and f4 i don't
i think that your real mistake came here
knight a4
okay so i would instead john focus on
developing your king side
and i would go bishop b2 now my
intention was to go c5 and black is
undoubtedly slightly better i don't
i don't think it's up for debate but if
you go bishop f2
no definitely i think from a positional
standpoint your move is perfect
from a positional standpoint but
unfortunately it falls prey to this
tactic knight takes e5 but here
you can let these pawns rush up the
board and then you can sort of try to
control the squares that the pawns leave
behind you can try to get the knight to
d6
and um you can try to do something like
this
i mean i think that would be probably
the most sustainable option and then i
would say
probably f takes e5 i understand but
bishop b2
you can i think limit the damage by
you know by quickly getting your pieces
out trying to castle at the very least
your king is not going to be caught on
the crossfire
um and i wanted to explain what would
have happened if you got bishop d4
so what i'm seeing here is that the
queen x-rays the bishop the queen
wants to get to e4 now bishops are or
any piece is notoriously bad at
being the intercepting piece a pawn is
the best square to have on a square like
d4 because
pieces are relatively easy to dislodge
if you attack them then they have to
move
so what comes to mind here yeah and john
is on the ball he moves c5
and c5 is devastating because if bishop
c5 then queen e4 wins the rook
and we're going to take a white's bishop
in response to bishop takes effect so
we're going to be up a piece
and if the bishop moves back to e3 then
of course we can just take e5
yeah so this is crushing bishop takes c5
bishop h6 is a good move
and yeah this is correct according to
the computer and here
i would probably still take and maybe go
queens maybe go queen c3 check but
the the reality is this is just winning
for black i'm going to be able to go
get e5 and then i'm going to get my
bishop out
um so yeah now queen g4 is an important
move
queen g4 is an important move and it
shuts down
white's play and you know there's really
nothing to be done here
so great game thank you john that was
that was a lot of fun
and um really not too many mistakes i
think just
mostly this this uh concept of not being
able to
go for the yugoslav instead go bishop c4
right castle king side so bishop c4
sorry not not here
um in this position bishop c4
uh castles and now bishop b3 that's by
the way another important move because
if you castle instead we play knight
takes e4 here
and then d5 and this uh this liberates
the position entirely